all right so paint the scene for me
where are we right here this is the war
zone when you're out rider first wakes
up from cryo sleep engine right into
this hellhole
and you know basically the idea is that
one of the aspects of the anomaly is
that it kills all electronics more
complicated than a light bulb so
humanity has been reduced to sort of
pre-world War One technology so that's
that's what this feels like it's like
trenches and tanks but on an alien
planet the enemy is you're fighting
these are the insurgents who are you're
the ECAs at war with yeah of course they
don't call themselves that they call
themselves the X Isles and you know
understanding the whole tragic story
behind this war is a big part of the
mystery that you're solving right now
we're looking at the trickster am I
correct in saying it yeah the trickster
yeah so now we see the temporal slice of
first ability you see that you are
slowing everyone and later killing them
right now this is low trap so that's
really cool
you are fast but you can even slow down
faster that's cool even bolt the bullets
going in slow motion inside that bubble
you're like totally neo body parts we
fly I noticed that your health was low
how did you hear though you're receiving
some part of the health through your
assassination it's the whole idea of
doing damage is what gives you your
health back and this right here is the
Devastator correct yes we are killing
them so the more enemies around you the
better and the skill we're seeing is the
earthquake so basically like better
shotgun so you can synergize it together
and kill a lot of enemies in the close
close combat oh the next kill which is
right now is the basically arm oh it's a
goner that's changing into the almost
indestructible guy yeah you can even be
more close
yeah marbot that's exactly what I need
can I be more tanky oh hey I like it I
like how his skin is like rock solid his
or her depending on which way you decide
to go on customization this is one of
the hub areas you were talking about
earlier if I'm not mistaken is this uh
rift town rift on yes there's a rift on
yeah this is one of the first large hubs
in the game you come to you know
basically like after the anomaly storms
have destroyed the first city and the
monsters have started coming and the
insurgency has started rising those who
are loyal to the ECA have retreated into
this rift for protection this is like
one of the first places on anak where a
kind of civilization has survived right
it is a harsh broken world yeah you find
in this place but it's also the first
time in the game that you really get to
slow down yeah and start to kind of
explore and start to kind of unravel
some of the mysteries that are a key
part of this game yeah it feels desolate
but hopeful at the very same time so how
does the loot system where I'm noticing
there's vendors cannot buy and sell
things with the vendors like gear or
whatever yes overall you are finding a
lot of stuff in the world you can scrap
you can destroy so you can receive money
for it so we our money is called scrap
basically okay and then if you have bad
luck let's say in the world finding the
cool load you can bite through the
vendors or maybe we are missing some
item that they want or maybe there will
be some mod do you want to purchase you
can do this through stop all right
how about that scrap keeping a rocket
how do I move from one environment and
get to the next so the story is carrying
you forward and the journey is really
important and every time you kind of
move you open up a whole new area
adjacent to your hub and once you've
captured an area so to speak you can
fast travel in between them oh is that
what that flag yeah okay that makes
sense where are we here so this is the
first city that I mentioned earlier okay
which is now totally in ruins yeah this
is a city I don't see a city it was
supposed to be this was sort of like
like the place that the colonization
started right that huge thing that we
saw on the horizon like dominating the
skyline so that's the engine of the arc
ship that brought us here and the whole
idea of the colonization plan was that
was going to be our nuclear energy
source that would power the city but
then the anomaly hit and that thing
melted down and it irradiated half the
city and you know those who could
escaped into rift town and those who
couldn't the X Isles were trapped out
here so this is this is now home base of
the insurgents that you're moving into
you're moving into their territory now
and okay I guess we're moving on here to
the Pyromancer this is a lot of fire
yeah all is about the fire and
this place is filled with enemies filled
with really dangerous monster what's
that yeah you're not fighting on it with
human I remember what we said on the
beginning that whatever am i touches it
changes ya as are the creature that
mutated from his four creatures now they
are not known that there is no cute
creatures anymore here because you are
powerful you are almost like we were
skills but the threat is even more
dangerous so have to fight us really
really nasty creatures in your journey
oh man alright that's gonna be fun
that's gonna be fun I'm not not like
into shooting creatures unless they're
like really scared so this is this is
right
you